- This is why I love when everyone's like,
oh I hate all this technology,
the old days were better.
Was it?
(crowd laughter)
(hip hop music)
- You got your perspective.
(cheering crowd)
I just wanna be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
(hip hop music)
There's this whole notion
of breaking the fourth wall,
Google it if you don't understand,
and so many of you ask
me so many questions
the answer's always Google it. (laughs)
Jesus.
- [Cameraman] I don't know (mumbles)
- What does he mean by that?
What are the Jones's?
Google that shit, baby.
If you can't Google stuff, you're not
going to be able to do anything
that I'm telling you to do.
I think I can do a better job of breaking
my own fourth wall and
explaining what I'm doing
in real time within in it.
I'm gonna go Instagram live.
Irving, it's that because first of all,
you are in control of some of your actions
and so many people dwell on shit
that they can't control instead
of realizing that they can control.
You could leave America, for example,
you could leave your wife, your husband,
you could change your job, you could stop
talking to your mom, you could.
The reason it leads to happiness
is once you're actually in the mindset of,
I'm in control, you're much happier
because you don't feel
like some bigger thing
is in control and you feel helpless.
And like, it's powerful as fuck.
You need to start recording sometimes
when you put it down because
we could get some good shit.
Are you recording now?
D-Rock just missed the moment,
I'm so into the flip life right now.
He was like, hey I need a new camera.
I was like, cool.
I was just sitting here working,
I was like, oh shit lets both sign
this camera and fucking sell
it and then buy five cameras.
And I'm not kidding, I'm
gonna fucking do that.
And guess what, the person that pays
the premium for the double side camera?
They're gonna make a
fucking fortune in 11 years.
They're gonna fucking sell it.
- [Man] Right.
- Flip life, I'm all about it.
Alright, D-Rock what's this?
This is the camera that
we were using, you and I.
- [D-Rock] Yep.
- And we're gonna sell this on eBay?
- [D-Rock] Correct.
- You're gonna sell this on eBay.
- [D-Rock] Seth and I.
- Seth and you are
gonna sell this on eBay.
And the plan is, we're taking this
three, 4000 dollar,
2000, 3000, what is it?
- [D-Rock] $4,000.
- $4,000 camera, you
and I are gonna sign it.
- [D-Rock] Right.
- And then we're gonna put it on eBay.
- [D-Rock] Correct.
- And see what happens.
- Yes.
- You're gonna tweet it
out, I'm gonna retweet it?
- [D-Rock] Yeah.
- I'm excited about this.
I can sign it anywhere?
- [D-Rock] Wherever you can.
- I'm so into this, D-Rock,
I'm so pumped by you.
This is so cool.
- [D-Rock] Wow, really awesome.
- Alright D-Rock, you're
gonna sign it too?
- [D-Rock] Yep.
- [Father] Where are you guys?
- I'm in Orlando about to go on stage.
- [Father] Oh and where's the kids?
- They're here, we came
down yesterday, we hung out.
- [Father] On a private plane?
- Yep.
(father laughs)
That's the only way,
knows how to travel.
- [Father] Oh my God, holy shit, yeah.
- Yep.
- [Father] It's finished.
- Yeah, it's all over, I
ruined everything, Dad.
Listen, I have to make sure that
I win in the end the only way I know how.
- [Father] Right right you sabotage it.
- I'm sabotage--
- [Father] That's what you're doing.
- Yeah as long, how could they
possibly be more hungry than me?
- [Father] That's right.
- I figured it all out, you know?
- [Father] When are you coming back?
- Tomorrow night, late tomorrow night.
- [Father] Okay. Alright.
- I'll see you, I love you, Dad.
- [Father] I love you, bye.
- Bye.
That's my dad's big theory,
he wants Xander and Misha
to be more successful
to me to stick it to me.
But he thinks that I've got a great
master plan of spoiling them, thus they
can never be hungry enough to defeat me.
Exactly true, it's true.
- [Gary On Video] So, I think it's about
accountability and humility.
I don't value your opinion
'cause I don't value mine.
I'm gonna do me and when I lose
I'm like, you're a fucking idiot.
And when it works I'm like, yeah!
So you're valuing yours but then
you're valuing someone
else's, I don't value either.
And just go.
- Ego man.
- [Gary On Video] And
then deal with it after.
- Ego's got to be fucking destroyed.
- [Gary On Video] I would just
rather die on my own sword.
- It's insecurity.
- [Gary On Video] But I'm
gonna do what I wanna do.
Because if it's wrong-
- And so you're so secure,
you build up a cactus around you, right?
- [Gary On Video] Guys,
when it ends up being wrong
you're gonna blame your parents,
and then that gets really hard.
- That's why I'm so attracted to kindness
it means so much strength.
- I stay fuckin' true
the whole time and never fucking wimp out.
Listen to yourself,
please, listen to yourself.
- Listen to yourself.
You coming out with me?
Yeah, do your thing.
Probably better, I don't
feel comfortable doing it
but you, you know what I mean?
(crowd cheering)
Regardless of how much debt you have
or responsibilities or I have to
feed my kids or put clothes on backs
or whatever your thing is,
debt or responsibilities
or most likely you
bought too much shit you
didn't need and now you have to work
to pay for that bullshit.
(crowd laughing)
Right?
I love the people that buy a home
that has four extra rooms
that they never fucking use.
(crowd laughing)
And then they have to keep a job
that they fucking hate to pay for
a house that has four bedrooms
that they never fucking use.
(crowd cheering)
I know, my guy.
Facts.
How many people here under 30?
(crowd cheers)
Lets clap it up for the youngsters.
Alright, under 30 you're not going to
believe this but us old fuckers, we
lived most of our childhood
without the internet.
And it was fucking crazy.
Let me tell you some stories, kids.
Let me tell you how I
tried to used to meet
up with my friends at the mall.
You would talk during school
and you'd be like, yo Ricky 4:30
at the fountain by fuckin Macy's, got it?
(crowd laughing)
Now here's where shit
got really fucked up.
And this is where I love
when everyone's like,
oh I hate all this technology,
the old days were better.
Was it?
(crowd laughing)
Because, I recall that
when I go to the mall
and can't wait to see Ricky to go play
fuckin' arcade games at the mall
but there was traffic or his mom was late
and I'd be at the fountain at 4:30
and after about 15 minutes
I'd have to give up and leave.
Then at the next day
at school he'd be like,
where, by the fountain at Macy's.
Fuck, I was down by KB Toys.
(crowd laughing)
Kids under 30, we used
to not find each other.
(crowd laughing)
We literally couldn't find each other.
Hello.
(clapping)
Thank you.
- [Man] I feel like I just
jumped into a Youtube video.
(laughter)
- Three dimensional Youtube video.
That's awesome, thanks for being here.
You're the uncle? (laughter)
- No.
- No, I'm kidding.
(laughter)
To me, it's time and talent.
The reason I love hard
work is it's controllable.
It's hard for me to be
like, be more talented.
Gary, it's unhealthy.
Gary V, you can't go to the
grave with all your money.
And I'm like, dude I'm
not talking about money.
And I don't feel like
it's work when I love it.
Maybe you don't like your job as much.
- [Woman] Is it wrong
to be driven by money?
- I don't think I can judge anything.
I think the question becomes,
what the next thing is.
To me it's like, what?
- It's a vehicle.
- Correct, correct, but I also think that
people confuse it, the vehicle then.
I think people don't often get
the right vehicle for the destination.
You're right, it's a vehicle.
Now my question is,
what's your destination?
And if you told me it was down the street,
I'd tell you to fucking walk
not drive a Lamborghini.
I don't think its an evil or it's wrong.
I think people are confused to
why they try to amass it and for what.
How much do you want to make?
It's arbitrary, what's it based on?
We have to unwind what's
been push in our heads.
20, 50, 72, four, nine, six, what?
To me, my big one is can I do
what I want to do everyday?
I was doing that running the liquor store
and I was making 57, I was happy as fuck.
I'm no more happy today than I was at 22.
I was pumped, I was on a mission
to build a family business
so big, so that everybody on Earth would
always say I did the
right thing by my parents
and the way they did to me.
I don't think there's anything
wrong with chasing money.
I just think that it's usually
the quickest way not to get it.
I really believe that, I really do.
When I watch people that are driven
by money, I see a lot
unhappiness and failure.
It's very common.
I think the question is why?
What do you need?
And do you have a sense of that?
Because, by the way, it evolves.
What he needed at 24 is
different than what he needs now.
And him, and me, and you
know, so it evolves, too.
If we did the happy meter here
I promise you it's the people
that are doing what they want to be doing.
To me, I couldn't explain to you enough,
and I have almost empathy for the
cynicism around this statement,
it's unbelievable how
much I don't like money.
I like the game, I love my game.
I love the game of building shit.
It's why building a legacy is the best
cause it's triple
compounding valuable, right?
I love the admiration, I love
the thrill and the chase.
I wake up at six o'clock
in the morning and go
garage sale-ing, because
there's nothing like pulling up,
literally to this day, I can't replicate
the high of going to a garage sale,
walking into a yard of junk and
finding something for a dollar
that I know I can sell
on eBay for 17 bucks.
It's a bigger happiness high than
closing a six million
dollar account for Vayner.
And it's not even close.
That's what I want for everybody
because that's how they get the 20.
I believe that, I really do.
I think the fear I have with chasing money
is it's short term behavior.
And it leads to a lot of negativity.
Even for the people that achieve it.
The reason a lot of people on wall street
go into really bad
places in their late 30's
and early 40's is the way
they made their money.
It's not something you're
proud enough about.
That's why optimism more often, works.
You know, it does.
But I do think you'd be thoughtful
about the chasing the money thing.
It will lead to a loss in
the macro, I believe that.
I could be wrong but that is
my official point of view.
And I've watched it way too much.
Cool, thanks guys, photos? Yeah.
Awesome, alright.
- Big fan.
- [Gary] I know it's tough bro.
You know what's even tougher?
Because of Vayner sports...
- You got this meeting now
then you have to be on in 20.
- On where in 20?
- On stage for the Q & A.
- Oh, shit. I forgot.
- If you want to hard stop, you only
have to be on there for 15 minutes.
If you want to go longer--
- What's my stop on the other end?
- [Organizer] You're going
to be on in about 18 minutes.
- Awesome.
- Sup, man.
- Such a pleasure, how are you?
- Pleasure, 'bout 10 years ago--
- Please sit.
- Oh. About 10 years ago I said to Anton.
I go who's this fuckin' guy who
talks like me, acts like me but he
articulates way better than me.
They go, who is he?
And I said your name and he's
like, are you kidding me?
Wine Gary V? I said, yeah.
I said, you got to be shitting me.
I want my friends to join it with me.
Almost in a guilt factor.
- I get it.
- And nobody seems to get that part.
They're like, what are you guilt about?
I'm like, it's not fun when
you're doing it by yourself.
(talking at the same time)
Come with me. Lets do this.
- Yeah, it's the best.
- And now I'm trying to transition.
I have asset, I do some real estate,
I do some other stuff like
that but I'm trying to find--
- You don't need to.
- What's the ticket for
me, what's the next,
Joe, what do you want?
My employees, if I'm traveling,
I let them stay at home, work from home.
I try to do everything
that nobody did for me.
- That's right.
- When I was growing up, right?
- But guess who set it up? Me.
Guess whose fault it was? Me.
- Brother, you're preaching.
You know this is, we're very similar.
- 10 years ago when I saw you, I said
this dude speaks like me, talks like me,
just more articulate than I am.
- I believe I create a lot of entitlement.
A lot, I believe it.
- Does that hurt?
- No, cause it feels so good to give.
- Yeah, but when you exp--
- What I'm doing better now is
giving more context around it.
What I used to do is,
here's a car payment.
What I didn't say is, here's
a car payment this time.
And D-Rock, just so you know,
I'm gonna give you the
car payment this time,
next time we might do something with
Billy Joel that's 10 times bigger
but I might want to take all that
money and invest it in the next business.
So next time you might get nothing.
- Right.
- I didn't used to do that.
- I don't do that.
- You can now, like I
said, you've gotta create,
you just have to over-communicate.
- Yeah, that's a downfall of mine.
- Me too.
- Yeah.
- You know why, 'cause
givers don't like to do that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Positive people don't like to do that.
- Right, yeah, but--
- You're taking some of
the energy out of the good.
- Yeah, but what starts happening
is then I start questioning why do I have
this satisfaction to make
sure that you're good?
- Because it makes you feel good.
It makes me feel good too.
That's a good thing.
- I've said that before.
- Don't let bad people tell
you that's a bad thing.
- Yeah.
- Let good people tell
you that a good thing.
I leave so much money on the table.
I don't even want to think about
how much money I leave on the table.
So?
- Do you find you lose
focus when you do that?
- No I think--
- It shakes me a little
bit, I need to be blunt.
- Here's what's shaking you, not leaving
the money on the table.
The entitlement you're creating where
you've now created
somebody thinking of you
negatively when you're
doing all the right things.
- That's a good point.
- It's what's happening, brother.
- So how do you fight against that?
- You start over-communicating.
I have employees that hate me when
I was fuckin' protecting them for a year
and then when they finally had to go,
and I didn't do the right thing.
Now I'm trying to communicate more
and I'm willing to take a little
bit more of the upfront negativity
because the way I was doing
it wasn't good enough.
That's what we're dealing with.
- And it's not just employees
it's even associates, really.
It's across the board,
okay, yeah, that's true.
- Sister, brother uncle,
niece, friends, homies.
- But I do get off on
it, I ain't gone lie.
- Me too.
- I get a sense of satisfaction
that I can't create.
- I'm literally trying to become the
nicest, most powerful person on earth.
'Cause the quench is so high.
But you will create entitlement.
- So, understand that, basically.
Like, shut up Joe, understand it.
- And continue to do things that create
more clarity, for example,
I wrote a book called, Crush It then
I write, Thank You Economy.
I don't think it's a coincidence,
in hindsight, that the book following
the Thank You Economy was
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook.
Thank You Economy was
about giving at scale.
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook was
give, give, give and then ask.
During Thank You Economy and
Jab, Jab, Jab, Right Hook
I was giving away at scale.
If I would do anything like,
hey there's a new book offer.
I have a new book out.
If I did it like twice in a week
people are like, you've changed Gary!
They're like, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa!
I'm literally trying to sell a $13 book,
you're fucking putting
people on a pedastal
that are charging you $8,000 for a course.
But because they created that expectation
and because I've created this expectation.
I think you keep changing your game.
I used to not say 7 years
ago, I'm comfortable
selling as long as I
believe in what I'm selling.
- Right.
- I did that in reaction to, oh shit
this isn't working the way I want to.
- But how did you scale your business.
My business from a service base
business, it's hard to scale it.
And when you're the guy they call--
- Vayner Media is a service base business.
My business right now, my
$150 million dollar business.
And with Gallery, my $200
million dollar business,
the VaynerX business
cause I have media part
of it as well and publishing
PureWow and 137pm.
it's a service based business.
- Yeah, but you have
somebody that runs it.
- I run it.
Who, who do I have?
- Yeah, but do you talk to every client.
- No, that doesn't mean I
have somebody running it.
That means somebody is
managing certain accounts.
- Okay, but in my situation, well
okay I would have a junior manager,
basically is what would have to happen.
- You're not going to be able to
get out of this one, you know that
- Yeah.
- Because Guy Oseary and
CAA and William Morris.
- Yeah, yeah as I was
talking I realized it.
- Thank you.
I run my business, you
can't manage every account.
So what do you do?
You start changing it, when
you sit down with Tina Turner,
you don't paint a picture that
you're gonna be the only one ever.
- D-Rock is your guy.
- That's right.
- You're gonna deal with him directly--
- And you got something
good going for you.
You have a huge advantage brother,
you're not driven by money.
Which means when you take a junior you
or a junior Akon or that whole crew
or D-Rock, who would be exactly the kind
of person who's a great human and you
walk in and you go Tina,
and you give D-Rock a bonus
of 20% on all net profit on Tina.
- He's running through the wall for me.
- And if he leaves and steals
Tina, you're still good.
- Yeah, yeah, that's a good point.
- That's the game, that's your game.
- But I have to get over
that feeling of why, why?
Why would you feel entitled when I do this
and why would you, there's
a why, which sucks.
- Ready for this, ready
for this ready for this?
- It's like an insecurity
thing, I know, I feel it.
- You're gonna love this, ready for this?
It's your fault.
- Okay, but how do I get over that?
- By communicating upfront
a little more context.
- Okay, back to the first point.
- That's it.
Dude, that's such a great photo.
I actually weirdly want that.
Usually I don't want stuff, as you know.
So can you help me?
Can you get it to the office, somehow?
FedEx or something.
- You stayin' in Orlando for a few days?
- I'm leaving tomorrow.
- [D-Rock] One, two, five.
- Get inspired more often.
What's his name?
- Huh?
- What's his name?
The person, do you know?
Antonio.
I genuinely love you.
(laughing) without knowing you.
Literally through his words.
- I don't care, I hate him.
- Through his words.
- Oh good, he's great.
- It's so nice the way he talks about--
I always think about the fun thing about
friendship is the best friends are
the ones that really talk the right
way about you when
nobody's paying attention.
The way he talks about
you it's really nice.
I'm glad we got...
- Hey, pleasure man.
- Yeah, real pleasure.
- Hey, can we see you
real quick, do you mind?
- Not at all.
- This is my nephew.
- How are you, Joey, nice to meet you.
- Joey.
- And my sister.
- Hi, I'm Carrie nice to meet you.
- I turned them on a year ago.
Ready one, two, three, and got it.
- Yeah, I'll send it to him.
- [Joey] Can I get one quick?
- Yeah, of course.
- I know you're in a rush.
- You guys enjoy the talk?
- Oh my gosh, man, unreal.
- One, two, three.
(Background Chatter)
- It's always great to see you, man.
(indiscernible chat)
- And it means the world...
- I wish I would have
brought my daughter here.
I appreciate it.
- Thank you, buddy.
Take care, bye, see ya, yeah, I hope so.
- [D-Rock] How's it going?
- [Announcer] Gary Vaynerchuk!
(crowd cheering)
- Thank you bro!
If somehow I could inject
you with perspective
on how early you are in the game at 45
it would change everything.
- [Man In audience] I think
I'm late, I'm watching--
- I know you think you're late.
I know you think you're late.
And I'm telling you, you're not.
(cheering woman)
Thank you back there, Mom.
(crowd cheering)
First of all, you're just not.
Sure you could get hit by a bus.
Sure you could terminal illness.
But a substantial chance that you're
barely getting into half time with
the advancement of modern medicine.
Everybody's got stuff but the thing
that you're deploying right now is
a frantic speed that lacks patience
because you do think you're late
because you're looking
back at how you did it.
Look at the way you communicated.
College, this and that.
That's cliche, it's cliche shit.
The way you sustain it,
is to slow the fuck down.
The way you sustain it is understand
you're just starting
I wish you understood.
For all the good that's happening
in my life and all the winning
that people perceive that I have,
I laugh when people think of it that way
cause I genuinely think I'm just starting.
You just have 20, 30, 40, 50, real years
of hardcore execution, you
just need to slow it down.
And you can't make it about
arbitrary things like numbers.
3,500; 4,700; 5,700;
68,000 it doesn't matter.
What you need to do is the right behavior
that gets you to the
place that you want to
and you need to be able to sustain it.
And all you really need
is shelter above your
head, clothes and a little bit of food.
It's about what do you need
and why do you need it?
But the biggest thing is slowing it down.
If I told you, you definitely would
be happy as fuck at 52, you'd take it.
You'd take it.
(applause)
So, I just think you have to slow it down.
(applause and cheering)
You know, you know, I
gonna make an audible here.
I'm in Orlando, my kids
are in Disney World.
What am I doing, doing
these calls in a hotel room?
I'm going to Disney and
spending time with them.
You know why I love talking to fighters?
I mean this, both boxers
and mixed martial arts?
Fighters, more than anybody I've met,
out of anybody I've met, fighters
understand strategy and business
more than anybody I know.
They understand such subtle things.
The reason I fell in love
with boxing as a kid is
it's nickname was the sweet
science, it's science.
I would watch fights
on Friday night fights,
I'm older I'm 42.
In America, there used to
be, I don't remember if it
was Monday or Tuesday, on
USA network, just fights.
I would watch.
It's because even a bullshit
fight that wasn't hype,
I was so intrigued by
the chess of the fight.
- The way it played out.
- Yeah, it's what I'm starting to
get into with UFC cause I'm starting
to understand slowly but surely, 'cause
I didn't understand
wrestling or jiu jitsu,
I understand the boxing stuff.
I understand it looks like it's going
to be a body punch, the
guy goes to block it.
Like Klitschko, Klitschko had
a lot of knockouts because
he was very good at the subtlest thing.
It look like he was setting
up a shot to the body.
What people don't understand
is how talented you guys are.
How much film you know, you know!
So it's very smart, I wish people knew.
Normal humans don't understand how smart.
They see the brute, It's so smart.
Which is why I love the
counter move to the move.
Klitschko knocked out a lot of people
because he had a way of tricking people
to make it look like he was going
to the body and he would go up.
He had a lot of left hook knockouts
cause he was very deceiving in the
way that he set up his body shot.
Which then allowed him, you know?
And it was funny, people would
watch and see the knock out,
I would have respect for the guy
that got knocked out cause I knew
he was being smart to try box-you know?
I'm very fascinated.
- It's a phenomenon.
It's interesting stuff.
But unfortunately, they cannot transition,
fighters sometimes hard to transition
into strictly business.
- Of course.
- And that's where--
- Because fighter
especially are employees.
You make your money by making a percentage
of what Dana White does well.
- Gary, thank you.
- Thank you, man.
- Appreciate it.
- Nice meeting you.
You want a photo?
Thank you, brother.
If I said to 27 year old, where do you
buy your art for your apartment?
There is no answer, that's the gap.
Aye, listen by the way, and I have no
interest in doing that to you and
I want to support it and that's
why I want to talk it through,
do you know what I mean?
How are you?
- Good, nice to meet you.
- Pleasure, nice to meet you.
- Thank you for responding to my tweet.
- Of course, brother.
- It's amazing seeing you in person.
- My pleasure, brother, thank you so much.
- Can I get you to sign
one of these pages in here?
- Let me get your other one so
I'll get a better signature.
- Sure.
Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- He was just telling me a few days before
he's like, Gary V replied to my tweet.
(chuckles)
- Thanks for coming guys,
thank you, nice to meet you.
- Gary fucking V right now!
- Thank you, brother.
- Am I on--
- You taking a photo?
- Yeah, I forgot, let's go.
- Question.
- Yes.
- I have a dropshipping
company and it's making money.
What do I do with the
first $5,000 that I make?
- It's a lot of money and
it's not a lot of money.
I wouldn't overthink what to do with it.
Do you know what I mean?
I probably would reinvest in what
you've been doing to turn
the five into, probably.
- [Man In Pink] Okay.
- Like, what else are
you going to do with it?
You know what I mean,
like you have a skill.
How much did it cost to get to the $5,000?
- Nothing.
- Put it into that.
- Can I get a selfie real quick?
- Sure.
- [Man] Love you, Gary.
- Love you guys back.
- Thank you.
- Oh, sorry, take care.
Thank you.
Hello, hello.
- Sup, man.
- Sup, thank you everybody,
I'm sorry I'm a little late.
Hi, how are you?
Hello, how are you?
Thanks for being here.
How's it going?
You guys gettin' to know each other?
You know to me, the biggest
thing that is absolutely
true for this room is what
I talked about at the end.
Which is, for every person here, finance,
hip-hop, whatever it may be, dentist,
it's very difficult not to get excited
about an under priced asset.
It's why I fuck with up-and-coming
hip hop artists because when Tee Grizzly
and Gunna and Young Pinch and
Russ and whoever they may be
are where they are two years ago
versus where they're
gonna be in three years,
that inevitably matters.
Back to like, who knows how?
Maybe I'm gonna want Gunna to perform
at my daughter's fuckin' Bat Mitzvah,
you know like I don't know, but I know
that under-priced assets
is just always a good idea.
I'm literally, this is not a joke,
I'm literally buying up
Hakeem Olajuwon rookie cards
because I think Africa is the
next continent to blow up,
and in 40 years, 40 years,
when Africa's on that stage
and Hakeem is the legend
for the number one
global sport next to soccer
which will be basketball,
I think Hakeem rookie's
that I'm now buying
for 110 dollars, are gonna be worth 4000.
- [Man] Well why are you
buying Barkley's then?
- What's that?
I'm buying Barkley's because I think
he'll be culturally relevant
and Panini just signed him to a deal
and I think he's gonna be in
the Zeitgeist over the
next three to five years.
And I enjoy that shit,
like I enjoy trading
emerging hip hop artists, I enjoy trading
social media platforms, wine, people,
it's just all the same kind of
one big macro game of like are you right
about what the world's gonna do.
It's why I'm so bullshit on China.
China agrees with me on Africa,
which is why they bought up all of Africa.
China the country's
playing bigger than I am,
I'm buying Hakeem rookies,
they're buying the country,
but you know, the continent, excuse me.
(man mumbles)
They made unbelievably
infrastructure investments,
so that's why I think, to your point,
whatever you feel the content
in your Instagram or Facebook,
you'll have to decide based
on your ambitions and wants,
short-term and long-term,
but the buy is right.
It's real estate, like if I told you
Malibu was gonna be Malibu 49 years ago,
you would buy beachfront property.
Would you need to build a beautiful house
at that moment because you
still lived in Florida?
Probably not, you might've
not done anything with it,
but you would've bought the property.
There's a belief that I
have on these platforms
that you should buy the property.
You can build a house on finance,
and then you could tear
it down in nine years
and built it around watches
'cause that's your passion.
Got it?
I believe you can be many things
as long as they're your true things.
I believe that Will
Smith can be Will Smith
after he was the Fresh Prince.
I believe that Mark Wahlberg
can be Mark Wahlberg
after he was Marky Mark.
(man mumbles)
Fair, but you know what I mean?
I believe that Dwayne Johnson can be
Dwayne Johnson, these are moguls,
that started off as not.
- But they had the passion.
They had the passion,
the drive, the ambition,
the creativity, the energy, and they had
the ability to have the humility
to do what they had to do
and they had the intention
to pivot and if they execute it
against the attention, they win.
That's what I do, I was the wine guy.
You know like if you can
execute against the attention
if you understand where the attention is,
you can do very big things.
Fuckin' 80% of that audience,
90% of that audience
would die to make 100 thousand a year.
And it scares me, let me say like
that is the word I want
to use, it scares me
how easy it is with enough education,
humility, you have the humility
to go to the Goodwill,
to go to a flea market,
to go to a Best Buy and load up a truck.
Like people don't like to be judged.
And when I go to the real bottom,
you know like because I win
in hip hop and other places,
I got fans who are like in it, in it,
like where 50 dollars matters.
Where they're like yo I
robbed three people today,
like I don't wanna do this
no more, Gary V help me.
Like shit that we will
not talk about today.
And I'm like okay, go to Craigslist,
go pick up shit for free.
The amount of people who are like,
just random tweets like,
holy fuck this is real,
I made 208 dollars in the last four days.
And it matters, and you
know, I was so fortunate
that I lived a life where 100 dollars
meant a hell of a lot more, like I know
where I thought 100 dollars meant
more to me than what a million, you know?
Like you know it, and you can taste it.
And you can only taste, my
kids will never know that.
Not that they're bad or
wrong or suck or entitled,
they just will never know.
I know nothing feels like the email
or DM I get they're like, Gary V,
I made 81 dollars 'cause I
went to fuckin' Goodwill today
and sold on Facebook, and
that's gonna buy dinner
this week for my family.
That shit fucks with me emotionally
like you would not believe.